القليل من الصور والكثير من الاهميه حدث
غير مسبوق في تاريخ الولايات المتحده يمثل
للمره الاولى رئيس سابق امام محكمه تحاصره
بتهم جنائيه قد تبقيه اذا ادينا عقودا خلف
القضبان من قبل وصوله المحكمه لن تجد
الصوره لترامب لكنه وفور دخوله مع فريقه
الى مقر المحكمه في ميامي خضع هو ومساعده
للاعتقال واخذت بصماتهما وفق ما اكدت
وسائل اعلام امريكيه نقل عن وزاره العدل
ان عمليه الاعتقال التي استغرقت 10 دقائق
تمت وفق الاجراءات القضائيه وتلاها دخول
ترامب قاعه المحكمه ومثله امام القاضيه
الفيدراليه التي تلت عليه لائحه الاتهام
في قضيه الوثائق السريه وبعد انتهاء
الاستماع دفع ترامب ببراءته من جميع التهم
الموجهه اليه واكد انه غير مذنب عقب
الجلسه سمح لترامب بمغادره مقر المحكمه
دون شروط
واوردت وسائل اعلام امريكيه انه لن تفرض
قيود على سفره ولن تفرض عليه ايضا كفاله
ماليه مقابل السماح بمغادره المحكمه لكن
بالمقابل قررت القاضيه الفيدراليه منع
ترامب من التحدث الى اي شهود محتمرين في
القضيه تفاصيل الشحيحه عن اجراءات هي اولى
حلقات محاكمه ستمتد تحت عنوان مواجهه سبع
وثلاثين تهمه
كان الظهور الاول للرئيس الامريكي السابق
عقب خروجه من المحكمه في مطعم وسط انصاره
بميامي بدا كان لم يخرج قبل دقائق من
محاكمه تحاصره بالاتهامات وتلقي كثيرا من
الغموض على مسار ترشحه مجددا لرئاسه
الولايات المتحده